good afternoon
let me start by thanking prime minister
kashida and the people of Japan for
their warm and generous welcome and
hospitality
at this pivotal moment for peace freedom
and democracy the G7 came together with
our allies and friends to confront a
more dangerous world
we leave Hiroshima stronger and more
united than ever
and through this Summit we have advanced
the priorities of the British people
with two big aims Economic Security and
National Security
first Economic Security
on this trip we've secured almost 18
billion pounds of new investments into
the UK from Japanese businesses
that's a huge vote of confidence in the
United Kingdom creating hundreds of new
jobs with significantly more to come as
projects get underway
all helping to grow our economy one of
my five priorities for the UK
and alongside our unprecedented new
defense and security partnership it's
clear that the UK Japan relationship has
never been closer as we work together
with G7 allies to support a free and
open indo-pacific
the G7 also demonstrated Unity of
purpose on China
poses the biggest challenge of our age
to Global Security and prosperity
they are increasingly authoritarian at
home and assertive abroad
and as the G7 have showed the UK's
response is completely aligned with our
allies
this is all about de-risking not
decoupling
and with the G7 we are taking steps to
prevent China from using economic
coercion to interfere in The Sovereign
Affairs of others
a new theme of this Summit was also AI
AI can bring huge benefits for our
economy society and public services
but of course it needs to be developed
safely securely and fairly
and that will require International
cooperation something that the UK is in
a natural position to lead
our second aim for this Summit was
National Security
all leaders at this Summit are grappling
with the issue of illegal migration
and my policy is this it is the British
government who will determine who comes
to Britain we must stop the boats and
break the business model of the criminal
gangs
this is a global issue and it will
increasingly be a focus of our
International engagement
just last week at the Council of Europe
we agreed to strengthen cooperation with
the eu's Border Force at this Summit we
secured the g7s agreement to deepen our
work together
and we expect this to be an important
focus of the G7 next year under Italy's
leadership
and there is no more pressing issue
facing the G7 and the world
the new crane
I want to pay tribute to my friend
Vladimir it was a privilege to welcome
him to Checkers earlier this week
and I believe his attendance at this G7
was a moment of historic significance
the image of the G7 and our partners
standing shoulder to shoulder with
president zielinski
sends a powerful message about the unity
and determination of the G7 allies
we will stand with Ukraine for as long
as it takes because their security is
our security
the G7 strategy is clear
our military diplomatic and economic
tools are all part of the Ukrainian
counter-offensive
we're delivering more support on the
battlefield through Air Defense
Artillery tanks and long-range missiles
which the UK was the first country to
provide
we're supporting Ukraine to develop the
Air Force it needs for the future
with the UK training Ukrainian Pilots
starting this summer
and we've made a real breakthrough at
this Summit thanks to President Biden's
support for an International Coalition
to provide F-16 Jets
we're ratcheting up the economic cost to
Russia with a new package of sanctions
and we know that Ukraine must not only
win the war
but win a just and Lasting peace
we're working with allies to provide
coordinated bilateral security
arrangements and a collective commitment
to Ukraine's future defense to guarantee
that they can deter future attacks
and any peace settlement must be on
Ukraine's terms
I want to just quote from the statement
that the G7 and our partner countries
have just agreed
we support a just and durable piece
based on respect for international law
the principles of the UN Charter
and territorial integrity and
sovereignty
in other words we must and we will show
that violent territorial aggression does
not reap Rewards
there could be no more fitting place to
discuss the urgent need for peace
than Hiroshima
I was deeply moved to visit the peace
Memorial on Friday
what we saw there was Haunting
a child's tricycle Twisted by the blast
school uniforms bloodied and torn
and with those images in our minds we
resolved never to forget what happened
here
and at this historic Summit G7 leaders
recommitted ourselves to the path of
peace
freedom and democracy thank you
we've got time to take some questions
from the media can I start with the BBC
please
thank you prime minister Chris Mason BBC
News will you ask the independence
advisor or Minister's interest to look
into your home secretary's conduct after
she asked civil servants to help her
deal with being caught speeding and do
you have full confidence in
did you have any questions about the
summit
others will I think
uh well Chris I don't know the full
details of what has happened nor have I
spoken to the Home Secretary I think you
can see firsthand what I've been doing
over the last day or so but I understand
that she's expressed regret for speeding
accepted the penalty and paid the fine
next can I turn to ITV
um yeah I have got a question about the
summit but just on that
simple issue if she asked her civil she
asked her officials for advice on A
Private Matter her penalty it's not
appropriate for a minister to do that is
it
um and then on China you say it presents
the greatest risk to our security and
our prosperity but then you talk about
de-risking not decoupling there's
nothing in this statement that will
deter the behavior of China is there
well Rob on your first question I'll
just refer you to what I said previously
um and I just respectfully would
disagree with you on China actually
there's complete resolve and unity
within the G7
first of all just recognizing the
systemic challenge that China poses to
the world order I think it's the only
country with both the means and intent
to reshape the world order Its Behavior
is increasingly authoritarian at home
and assertive abroad that's something
that I think all of us recognize and
what we have done in the statement is
make it very clear that we will work
together as the G7 and other countries
to make sure that we can de-risk
ourselves and the vulnerability of the
supply chains that we've seen from China
take the steps necessary to protect
ourselves against hostile investment and
do so in a way that doesn't damage each
other we also had conversations about
ensuring that important technology
pertinent to our security does not leak
to to China and then also steps taken to
stop Chinese economic coercion in other
parts of the world I think taken
together that represent quite a
substantive set of policy measures
backed up by a completely unified
resolve and commitment amongst the G7 I
think it sends a strong signal to China
that we believe in the rules-based
International System and we will work
very hard together to protect it against
the challenge that China poses and
that's certainly what we've done in the
UK just recently using our new powers to
block hostile investment in the
sensitive Semiconductor Company and we
keep a Vigilant eye on other areas where
we might be at risk and we will always
take the steps necessarily to protect
ourselves but I think the message coming
out of this Summit is that our approach
is totally aligned with that of our
allies and we are all very clear-eyed
about the risk that China poses
next can I turn to Skye thank you um
prime minister a couple of questions if
I may um just on Sola bravaman reports
that the Home Secretary are civil
servants to help her avoid a speeding
fine make some mockery of your
government of Integrity is she becoming
a liability to your own reputation and
on Ukraine president macron said
zelenski's visit was a game changer
Chancellor Schultz said the supply of
fd-16 shows Russia it shouldn't expect
to succeed by prolonging this war
do the Jets and the actions this weekend
bring you crane closer to peace and is
it also an admission by the G7 that we
are going to be in this for many many
years to come
well Bethany your first question again I
just refer you to what I said previously
on the on the substantive issue of
Ukraine and what this Summit means for
Ukraine I think they're probably three
three important things for me the first
is President zelenski's presence here I
think that in and of itself was a very
powerful moment to see President
zielinski standing shoulder to shoulder
with his G7 allies I think sends a
powerful message to Russia and the world
that we are united behind president
zielinski and his people and will
continue to support him for as long as
it takes I think the second thing coming
out of the summit was the very tangible
progress on providing further support to
Ukraine and most notably from President
Biden with the announcement on f-16s
which is very welcome you'll know this
is something that I've spoken about in
the past and just last week I was
discussing this with Mark Ritter from
the Netherlands and making it clear that
we had made provision to start training
Ukrainian Pilots incredibly soon
something that Vladimir and I have
discussed a lot over the past few months
and then I think the third the third
important thing is a conversation about
peace
that we had in the last session together
with the partner countries that have
been invited and making it very clear
what the principles of that piece should
be based on I think those calling for
peace but really meaning a ceasefire
should recognize that that not that is
not a just and durable piece and I think
that was recognized in the statement
that was put out a just and durable
piece is one that should be based on the
UN Charter about respect for territorial
Integrity for sovereignty those are the
values that underpin the International
System those are the values that we will
fight to Champion and no one wants peace
more than president zielinski and the
people of Ukraine but it has to be based
on those principles in order to be just
and Lasting
um could I turn to the Daily Mail next
thank you
thanks Priam um you mentioned uh uh
illegal immigration came up can I ask
you about legal immigration uh you you
said this week uh you're committed to
reducing levels below the level that
you've inherited that's about half a
million people what would you say to
people who voted for you at the last
election on the basis that you'd keep it
below half of that do you owe them an
apology and On a related issue some of
your colleagues think of a too many
foreign students coming to Britain
staying for too long bringing too many
dependents uh even the head of the
migration advisory committee says
there's no good reason for something to
be staying so long do you agree with
them and what are you going to do about
it now on on the topic of legal
migration let me be crystal clear I
think the numbers are too high and I'm
committed to bringing them down without
getting into specific measures to go to
a second question Jason I'm not going to
get into the specific means about that
we're obviously considering a range of
options to bring the numbers down and
we'll have more to say on that shortly
um but let me be unequivocal I think the
numbers of legal migration are too high
and I'm committed and the government is
committed to bringing those numbers down
as I've also said I think the British
people are very keen to see action on
illegal migration that's one why one of
my five priorities is to stop the boats
wherever I am that's what people talk to
me about and you know we're here in
Japan and last week I was in Iceland but
I think what people at home will be able
to see is we are putting this topic on
the international agenda you know is
that last week when I was in Iceland
discussing this with multiple countries
opening up negotiations with the EU for
greater cooperation between frontex the
eu's Border agency and the UK that will
be of real practical value in our
ability to break the cycle of criminal
gangs and to tackle illegal migration as
you've seen here language in the G7
communicate about breaking criminal
gangs to tackle illegal migration and as
I said it will be I think a feature of
the Italian G7 presidency next year
because this is a global challenge it's
not just the UK that faces increasing
illegal migration it's many countries
the numbers were up 50 60 percent on the
European continent last year so you will
expect you should expect me to keep
bringing this topic up in international
Forum like this and to keep making
progress with our allies so that we can
tackle this issue together and that is
yielding real benefit for people at home
you saw that with my engagement with
Albania where we have a new returns
agreement where we've now sent over a
thousand illegal migrants back to
Albania which is a very positive step
and the engagement that we've had with
the French and president mackerel in the
recent Summit which again is leading to
Greater cooperation of British and
French
Personnel in northern France as well so
look these are these are real tangible
outcomes from International engagement
which will help us stop the boats and I
know that is a priority that people have
uh Hugo Jai from the eye thank you prime
minister you've talked about the uh way
that diplomacy can help boost Britain's
economy
um British car companies are warning
that the industry risks uh collapse if
new post-brexit trading rules take
effect next year what specifically have
you been asking EU partners for on this
and what will you ask them for will this
include pushing the deadline back from
next year to 2027.
I think the issue that you've raised
Hugo is one that has been raised not
just by car manufacturers in the UK but
also car manufacturers across Europe and
as a result of that we are having
conversations with the EU about the best
way to address some of those concerns
but more broadly I would also just point
everyone to the first day of this trip
when I was in Tokyo and announced 18
billion pounds of investment into the UK
economy that's a massive vote of
confidence in the UK Nissan in
particular already has a billion pound
investment plan for electric vehicles
with Envision in the Northeast
and as you saw at the beginning of the
trip there's just enormous interest and
excitement about the opportunities in
the UK and a willingness to invest in it
in a range of different sectors and not
just in automotive but also in clean
energy offshore wind
and other high growth sectors in the
technology space all of that is good for
people at home because it's going to
create jobs hundreds of jobs in the
short term more over the long term and
strengthening our Economic Security
growing our economy is very important to
me and that's where the international
engagement can make a real difference
and you saw very tangibly on the first
day of this trip you know that
engagement resulting in significant
investment into the UK big vote of
confidence and crucially that will help
us grow the economy and create and
support many jobs not just in automotive
sector but many others too
and lastly we've got time I think for
one more uh we're going to go to the Rio
Sonata
from them
thank you prime minister uh I'm India
Sanada from assassin and I'd like to ask
you a question regarding the invitation
of President tensky uh I think Britain
jiren's kid participation was a great
significant significance at this Summit
and I believe there has been a
tremendous effort in inviting him to
Japan
uh what efforts has the UK made and what
role has the UK pride in bringing him to
Japan and what are your expectations of
Japan and the world in inviting
president zinsky to this Summit
well real I think you're right to say
that President zielinski's attendance at
this Summit was hugely significant I
think of historic significance for the
reasons that I outlined earlier and you
know whilst
I have had conversations about this uh
with president zielinski in the past
it's actually prime minister kashida
that deserves the praise it's Japan's
presidency of the G7 and prime ministers
kashida leadership of it that has led to
this outcome and he deserves enormous
credit for extending the invitation to
president zielinski and ensuring that
the summit was successful and I think
more broadly Japan the Japanese people
and prime minister kashida deserve
enormous credit
when the Ukraine conflict broke out and
Russia's illegal and provoked war was
started you know Japan demonstrated that
our security is indivisible regardless
of where we live whether that's in the
Pacific or in Europe and the Atlantic
because the values which we all hold
dear are Universal democracy Freedom the
rule of law those values are the same in
Japan as they are in Ukraine as they are
in the United Kingdom and the Japanese
people have demonstrated their
commitment to those values by supporting
Ukraine in the way that they have and
prime minister prime minister kashida
has exemplified that by his leadership
particularly of the G7 but in particular
with regard to supporting Ukraine in
this conflict and I think he should feel
incredibly proud as should the Japanese
people of how successful this Summit has
been in demonstrating Unity of the G7 in
supporting Ukraine but also engaging
those countries from the so-called
Global South that prime minister kashida
has spent an enormous amount of time
with over the past several months and I
think that is something that is very
welcome because it's important for the
G7 to demonstrate that it is engaging
listening with all countries from all
parts of the world and responding to
their concerns too and that's what prime
minister prime minister kashida has done
so brilliantly and I said I'm very
grateful to him and the Japanese people
not just for a successful Summit for
their incredibly warm Hospitality over
the past few weeks on a personal note
it's been a great pleasure to be back in
Japan after a long time and I
particularly enjoyed my economyaki
making the other day which I've had lots
of people talk to me about and prime
minister kashida pointed out to me that
how we do that or how you do that here
in Hiroshima is different to how they do
it in Tokyo and different uh Osaka
um I'm sure he'd he'd say that the
Hiroshima ones are the best and I have
no reason to disagree but they uh it's
been delicious and the hospitality has
been incredibly worn so thank you very
much to you your country for what you've
done over the past few weeks thank you
very much
foreign